des aboiements dans une spa rien
d'anormal mais il ya aussi ces quatre
petits chiens bien moins agitée que les
autres cela fait trois jours que la spa
s'en occupe
ils vont beaucoup mieux grâce à une
réalimentation progressive
seule cette chienne est encore faible
elle va devoir subir une césarienne son
chiot mort dans son ventre avait échappé
à l'éleveur c'est elle qui je tairai qui
a été la plus animée
voilà donc elle a un problème de peau
dermatologiques important alors non
est-ce que c'est lié aussi à l'humidité
peut-être aux acariens aux fins titus et
ses parents envoyez-les tremble beaucoup
plus que les autres
de plus en retrait mercredi à mme halimi
seuls trente et un chien ont pu être
sauvés de l'élevage impossible de savoir
combien ils étaient au total et combien
sont morts
il pourrait s'agir d'une vingtaine de
cadavres du jamais vu dans le
département parfois on a des élevages
qui sont en liquidation judiciaire
donc nous on a mission de récupérer les
animaux sont généralement des animaux
qu'ils sont
très perturbé qui ne connaissent pas
trop la main de l'homme qui sont très
craintif mais voilà qui ne sont pas dans
cet état où qu'ils ne sont pas morts un
constat qui doit aussi aboutir à un
procès dans un mois et demi tant que
l'éleveur est poursuivi en justice pour
mauvais traitements et privation de
nourriture
aucun chien ne quittera ce refuge et la
spa de messigny et vantoux doit se
constituer partie civile pour demander
un retrait définitif du cheptel
l'éleveur lui qui a accepté de nous
répondre par téléphone se dit fragilisé
par sa situation familiale compliquée et
instable il doit passer une expertise
psychologique et quelque part ça permet
de reposer j'avais connu ça
et puisque par des poursuites pourraient
aussi être engagées contre la femme de
l'éleveur elle est accusée de complicité
pour maltraitance animale et détention
de cadavres